God of War Ragnarok will soon be here as
Kratos navigates his way through the
Norse apocalypse yet while the end times
may be upon Kratos there are those who
hope to stop the coming final battle
including the greatest of the Acer Odin
himself
while we never met Odin in God of War
2018 his presence was certainly felt in
his impact the most notable was upon
Freya Odin's former wife and the tale of
Odin and Freya both in Legend and the
game is a fraught one and one which will
lie at the center of God of War Ragnarok
so my gods of lore let's take a look at
the history of Odin and Freya in Norse
mythology discuss how that compares to
their God of War counterparts and what
that might mean for God of War Ragnarok
in myth long ago two tribes of Norse
gods were at war with each other the
Acer and the veneer little was known
about the vanir saved that the war was
long and painful for both sides
eventually though the war came to an end
though we don't understand why many of
the veneer including one called Freya
soon became friends with the Acer with
Freya herself even being considered an
honorary Acer this history is actually
fleshed out slightly more in God of
War's lore in the game the reason for
the War ending was caused by the god
memir's suggestion of a marriage between
Odin the king of the Acer and Freya who
in this version was the leader of the
warrior Valkyries this marriage would
symbolize the end of fighting between
the veneer and the Acer something Freya
agreed to in order to stop the Bloodshed
this story makes the game's version of
Freya an amalgamation with another God
from Norse myth the goddess frigg who in
mythology wasn't a seer who looked
precisely like Freya but was the one
married to Odin some sources in Norse
myth cite them as the same person and
others say that they were distinct gods
and this is a discrepancy that God of
War itself would eventually play upon I
always heard that balder's mother was
free i Frank well that's more of a pet
name you see it means beloved something
Odin called Freya after they wed out of
affectionate first or so I like to
believe in the game's World Freya
ultimately chooses to leave Odin due to
his cruelty causing Odin to cast her out
of the Acer and take her wings leaving
her to live alone in isolation
we're here you live in a tree not in it
below it
Heavenly look
it's all right
thus the game explains the discrepancy
between Freya and frigg as Freya plays
the role of both Odin's wife and not yet
what motivated Odin's cruelty that led
to Freya leaving him while many
depictions of Odin today in pop culture
like in the MCU movies show him as a
wise and kind ruler in Legend Odin was
nothing of the sort unlike Thor who was
seen as a god of the people and Noble in
his cause Odin often saw himself above
those in his charge he enjoyed pitting
gods and human beings against each other
simply for fun and to give him a chance
to earn glory for himself in battle to
Odin it was War and the Deeds Done
therein that made men not nobility
virtue or honor he was even the favorite
God of Outlaws and those who like to
live on the outside of society's rules
often helping them gain a legacy as
Warriors so bad was Odin's reputation
that he was even cast out by the Acer
from Asgard for 10 years at one point
despite him being the a ruler yet the
Odin ain't God of War is perhaps even
crueler than the one of Legend as
instead of Simply being an uncaring
figure as he was in myth in the world of
the game he manages to lead others to
Cruelty as well in the backstory to God
of War Odin pushes Thor and the other
Acer into battle with the yotin the
Giants he turns his own people into
cruel soldiers rather than just himself
because if there's anything that this
version of Odin seeks it is power and
fame above all but Odin's true face
shoot itself again in the end well he
won freya's trust and she taught him
some of Albanian magic another Choice he
would live to bitterly regret
sadly despite his wise counselor's best
efforts to persuade him that peace was
the only true path to Stave off Ragnarok
or didn't never let go of his obsession
with jotenheim
Taste of Vania magic led him to new
forms of experimentation and new levels
of depravity
this desire for power though does match
up with Odin in myth who is willing to
use any power at his disposal to get
what he wants unlike Thor and many other
Asia who fight with strength and tools
alone Odin is happy to use magic cunning
and trickery to stay in charge he often
finds himself walking the Earth in other
Realms searching for new ways to gain
power for himself if this sounds
familiar to you it should as Odin is
meant as a dark reflection of another
Acer Loki in myth Loki met Odin for the
first time as they were both wandering
the nine Realms eventually becoming
Blood Brothers a story I told in my
video about Loki yet after Loki joined
the Acer he was often considered the
black sheep of the Gods for his trickery
and his playfulness something that
eventually bothered Loki so much that he
drunkenly called out the gods one night
for their hypocrisy in retaliation Odin
called Loki not much of a man accusing
him of spending time on Earth as a woman
and bearing children saying that it
batokes a base nature in Loki angry at
this accusation Loki calls Odin out for
his own hypocrisy saying but it is said
thou wintest with tottering steps in
samso and knocked at houses as a Vala a
serious in likeness of a fortune teller
thou wentest amongst people now that me
thinks butoks a base nature Loki here is
saying that Odin was doing much the same
as Loki even using forbidden women's
magic like fortune telling to gain
wisdom for Odin sought knowledge and the
ability to learn about the future Above
All Else
if it's about the future he adds it to
his collection helps him style himself
as all seeing and all-knowing but of
course the idea is control control of
the future control of his feet he
control every realm of every land in
every world if he could every potential
pocket of resistance he seeks to
eliminate and in the future is very much
a concern of Odin in God of War the
reason Odin set Thor and the rest of the
Acer against the Giants was in order to
gain the Giant's ability to read the
future as Odin wished to stop the coming
of Ragnarok as he knew the final battle
at the end of the world was on its way
and wanted to learn how to prevent it
and he knew one of the signs of it
coming would be the death of his son
balder yet balder was freya's son too
and she feared for his death not out of
self-interest like Odin but as a loving
parent so Freya put a spell upon balder
making him Immortal yet numbing him to
all feeling and pain and the ability to
empathize with others feasting drinking
women
so God
God feel pain again death has no power
over you now you would rather die
yes take it away I can't please please
please take it away it doesn't work like
that
instead of caring for balder Freya
viewed him as an object that she wished
to protect instead of caring about his
wants and Desires in many ways Freya was
displaying a selfishness more akin to
Odin than she would want to admit yet
Freya spell caused baller's
invincibility and it was a power that
Odin took advantage of and used for
himself sending balder as his agent to
track down Giants who had fled Odin's
War this eventually led balder to Kratos
who Odin had sent after to look for
kratos's wife a giant who had died
before the beginning of the game sending
them off on an adventure where they
eventually run into Freya herself who
helps them and even saves atreus's life
much to her later regret because as in
myth atreus leads to the death of balder
this was the one event that Freya feared
most yet it was caused by her empathy
for Kratos and his son if she hadn't
saved atreus who was later revealed to
be Loki balder might have survived
because Loki was destined both in Norse
myth and in the game to lead to balder's
death and even has a role in the
eventual fate of all the gods themselves
as it is said that Loki will lead an
army of Giants against Odin leading to
the final battle at Ragnarok in Norse
mythology when Loki attacks Asgard with
the Giants Odin will eventually be
forced to start the final battle leading
to him fighting the Great Wolf fenrir
who will swallow him whole killing the
all-father this knowledge of his future
death during Ragnarok is perhaps why
Odin in the game was watching Kratos
through his ravens as he always feared
balder's death though not out of concern
for his son's life but for his fear of
Ragnarok coming Odin now knows who
stands in his way if he wishes to
survive and prevent his fate yet this
aligns him once again with Freya who
also seeks Vengeance against the former
Greek god of war and his son atreus for
killing her child balder
I will parade your cold body
from every corner of every realm and
feed your soul to the vilest filth in
hell that is my promise he saved your
life he robbed me of everything
while empathy for others guides Freya
while Odin is deeply selfish there are
paths and attention towards their son
Boulder still LED them back to where
they began a lie together against a
common goal to bring down the former
Greek God of War it is fitting then
perhaps that in nor Smith Odin and Freya
also hold a particular title themselves
the god and goddess of war and so this
is where God of War Ragnarok begins with
the Norse gods of War about to face off
against the former Greek god of war and
the battle may lead to the end of the
world itself but if you want to learn
more about Norse mythology and how it
may tie into God of War Ragnarok don't
forget to subscribe to Gamespot as we'll
have more God of lore videos next week
and in the meantime check out all of our
coverage on God of War Ragnarok right
here on Gamespot
[Music]
foreign